one thing i i admire about you and
something that i actually decided to do
myself is that you
you ran a real business in the real
world
before you came on the internet yeah and
so i really wanted to take some time and
just talk through a couple of talking
points about real business in the real
world versus the internet because i
think a lot of guys
even though ideally they're gonna
they're gonna try to gravitate towards
internet some of them are not
and i think there's something to be said
about a guy that can create a real
business and and succeed
in a normal traditional style of
business
yeah far away man what do you got for me
yeah so the first one is you know i
wrote down you know it's not a fairy
tale
and so
i know that there was probably trials
and tribulations that came i know that
people kind of come in and try to steal
your model things like that
what uh what challenges did you face on
an everyday basis when when it came to
your business oh man that's a good
question um there's a lot you know if
i'm being honest because um i mean the
whole point of a business is is to
create
value and a profit for the shareholders
um a lot of people think that they're in
business or they'll call themselves
entrepreneurs or you know you see some
women out there they'll be like hashtag
boss girls sort of thing and they don't
really have a business um
to me a business is really defined as as
as something that's gonna generate over
a million dollars a year in annual sales
whatever your margins look like it
doesn't matter as long as it's
profitable and it generates over a
million dollars a year in sales that's
the proper business and you're going to
run into all kinds of interesting
problems
that you're going to need to create
solutions for i've often said and i
don't think enough of like the big boy
entrepreneurs like the like the like the
billionaire boys sort of cover this
enough when they're doing their talks
but
the most important skill that you need
to develop as an entrepreneur is going
to be problem solving skills
right because that because that's really
what you're doing a lot of right there's
a lot of fires that pop up
you're going to have legal issues you're
going to have hr issues you're going to
have competitor issues you're going to
have employee issues there's all kinds
of things that are going to pop up and
if you're not
if you're not resilient
and you know can can solve these things
as they come at you
um
you're just not going to make it i mean
that's why nine out of 10 businesses
fail and then of the one out of 10 that
make it i think the number is something
like within the first five years
most of those fail as well and any that
that that like you know continue into
perpetuity
yeah um they don't even make a million
dollars a year in sales like something
like 97 or 98
of businesses that succeed you know past
that failure point
they're never doing over a million
dollars a year in sales so
the guy that runs that um you know
hardware shop down the street the dry
cleaner the corner store guy the
you know whatever the guy that's the
gunsmith the guy like you know whoever
they are out there that that are
you know running businesses you know
they got their own business card sort of
thing
um they've generally created something
to just employ themselves and they're
just self-employed
yeah i completely agree man you know
i i think i think the statistic is
whatever 90 something percent don't make
it past make it to 5 and then of what's
left another 90 something percent go out
before 10 right
it's some unrealistic number and and i
think you're dead on there it does come
down to problem problem solving and your
ability to be tough i often say about my
business
uh we'll we'll make 11 years in march
and we'll do multi-million we'll do over
10 million this year
and i always say
it's not because i was overly talented
so much as it was i was just either too
dumb or too tough to quit right and and
that's just part of it man and i think a
lot of guys have an unrealistic
expectation a lot of times because
internet people saying oh you know and
in a couple months you can be doing you
know 300 grand a month
and i just man in all honesty i think
when when there's a gap between
expectation and reality especially when
it comes to business
people tend to quit faster because they
think that either something wrong with
them or that it's the wrong model so
they switch they switch gears they don't
stay in the same fight
how long how long how long
you know
from the start of your business to when
you kind of knew you had it up and
running how long did it take you
um
i think i i knew that i had something
going within about three or four months
because
i was i was pulling in like 35 45 000 a
month um this was around 2003 or four i
think around 2003
and that was a lot of money like that
was a lot of money you know
and you know i was getting paid when i
was an employee i don't know four or
five thousand dollars a month so to you
know put a business together that within
a few months was was generating you know
close to 50 grand you know we got to 50
grand you know very quickly after that
um it was really something to behold and
then you know then you run into other
problems too where it's like okay
now that i've got this thing running and
it's an oiled machine and like every
month i'm it's it's it's throwing off 50
60 75 000 in profit after you've paid
all your expenses and again this is back
in 2003 2004
you start to run into problems you're
like oh i need an accountant i got
to deal with taxes and i have like hr
issues and i you know i got to withhold
certain taxes for the government for
employees like employer health taxes and
insurance taxes and all that sort of
stuff and it's like you know i remember
talking to the accountant at that time
within the first year and and uh you
know he comes out he just starts yelling
at me i had a big stack of paper and he
comes down he goes what the were
you thinking i'm like what what are you
talking about he goes
why did you do this this and this and
the other thing i'm like look
you're the account you fix those
problems i don't need to deal with those
problems right like you know don't make
these particular problems yeah right
you know like he was all good about it
but he's like you know what you have
here rich is you got the goose that lays
a golden egg and i don't know if you
know this but
most businesses never get to this point
it's like i've been in accounting for a
long long time what you created here is
something that's resilient something
that's going to last long and it
basically craps out a golden gate every
single month and i was like okay i got
you i feel you and it's like okay well
that was fun and easy but you know the
years after that then there's new
problems that come up you have you have
people that you do work for
and um like i remember this one time
around 2004 2005 as a few years into it
there was this guy that i had worked for
about five or six weeks
and just just because the way the thing
was structured at the time um
he he got away with not paying me for
the work and i was living man like i was
like i was ready to just like do things
that would have been illegal that might
have put me in jail like it was just
been there you know been there thinking
about stuff like that i was like this
sucks right like i was out 15 grand or
something like that for the work that i
had done and i had vowed at that time
never to
expose myself you know in such a way
where
i would work for somebody for free in an
environment like that so you have to
okay all right so you know so let's plan
it out let's adjust you know you got to
pivot and i think that business um you
know it's going to be 20 years in in
2023 so next year it's going to be a 20
year old business and i'm still
partially involved in it
um we've probably pivoted about
four or five times in a very dramatic
way
right so that's the other thing that you
got to get good at you know as a guy you
know when it comes to competency skills
and if you're going to run a business is
you have to recognize when
going in this direction doesn't work and
it's like it might be a 17 degree pivot
in that direction might be 45 degrees in
that way but you have to realize when
you're up against something that you've
got a you've got to find a way like
sometimes it's an immovable object and
you got to go over it you got to go
around it there's a great book by ryan
holiday it's called the obstacle is away
so it's a recommended read that i talked
to guys about but yeah it's it's um it's
a fascinating journey and there's
nothing like it dude there's there's abs
i mean like you know because you're an
entrepreneur but there's absolutely
nothing like it
i absolutely agree man um some of the
times i felt most alive in my life
is where my back was against the wall in
the business yeah you know i in fact in
some ways i there are times where i miss
that i miss that feeling
i want to look back to something you
said it
you know you talked about you know it's
not a real business
unless you're doing seven figures i
agree with that absolutely
in addition to that i'd like to add
what level of freedom do you have did
you create a very very high paying
prison for yourself
or a very high revenue prison for
yourself without the net profit i'm not
talking to you directly but
my question to you is what level of
freedom do you feel like a person should
be able to acquire in their business in
order to be able to call it a business
and not a job
i think that you have to structure in
you know such a way that you eventually
achieve the freedom that you're looking
for you're not going to have it i'm
going to tell you straight up right now
i mean the first few years in most
businesses
most about 90 of them
you're gonna be handcuffed to it doing
pretty much everything
um i mean i still work all the time if
i'm being honest like i like oh sometime
sometimes i'll wake up at four o'clock
in the morning you know i'll have a
notepad and i gotta write down some
because i have an idea for a video or
something that i gotta do and i'll just
go back to sleep right so it's like you
never really stop working but now i've
created my life in such a way that if i
do have to work on a sunday or a friday
night or you know at four o'clock in the
morning um it's doing something that i
love and i don't consider it work
um so i mean like the framing of
you know are you a slave to the business
i think that for the most part you
should expect to
basically be everything i mean you're
going to be the guy that
empties the garbage bins you're going to
be the guy that wipes down the white
board in the office you're going to be
the guy that um you know does the hr
stuff the tax planning the
basic accounting before you send
everything over to the accountant you
know a lot of that's going to fall on
your lap for the first little bit until
you hash it out and then after that then
you know once you figure that part out
then in that business later on or maybe
the next business that you're in you're
not going to do that stuff you
know that the accountant would normally
have to do because you've already
figured out and you know how to read the
tables you know what the quickbooks
looks like and all that sort of stuff
um yeah most guys don't understand what
what it is that you're gonna take on
when you create a business
um it's it's it's it's monumental it's
monumental for most people all right i
think it's the same substantially harder
than than people give it credit for
that's way true it's very sexy to say
i'm an entrepreneur it's very very
emotional like it's very chic today
right a lot of people will say and do
that and say okay you know that's cool
so what were your annual sales last year
right it's like you know 300 000 well
that's cool it's a nice start you know
like how long you been doing that well
eight years well that's okay well
that's gonna keep talking right you know
my time is three thousand dollars an
hour man you know if you want help with
that yeah no i absolutely agree with you
when it when it came to scaling for you
how did you go about
choosing when to delegate how did you
make the decision did you
did you
kind of identify the things you're doing
on a daily basis and and say okay well
this is where this would go in an
organizational board or how did you make
those decisions when you decided to
scale and how did you find success in
scaling yeah so i mean you want to get
clear on what you like doing and what
you're good at
and then you have to get clear on what
you don't like doing and what you're not
good at and if you don't like doing
something and you're not good at it
outsource it
contract it out or just stop doing it
all together if it's not important you'd
be surprised how much i see guys do
in their business because they think
it's important and all they have to do
is just like set that aside
it's like you know like when you talk to
guys and they're all hung up over a girl
and they're like i don't know what to do
and she's banging chad right now you
know they can't sleep and all that sort
of stuff it's like dude you got all this
resentment and guilt around what
happened there and all you got to do is
like that's like a burlap bag full of
bricks that you're carrying around your
back nobody cares just put it down and
walk away from it there's a lot of stuff
that entrepreneurs can just like not do
right so getting clear on what you're
good at and what you like to do that's
where you want to focus your time and
then when you figure out what you're not
good at and what you don't like doing
that's what you can contract out hire
people to do or just not do at all i
agree with you 100 what i always say on
that subject is like what do i have
energy for you know there's those things
in business where
you do them and nobody else wants to do
them but you actually enjoy doing the
task so for that reason it's not taxing
to you yeah and then there's those
things that are absolutely waterboarding
like one for me is estimating i cannot
stand going through a stack of drawings
this big so i can bean count on a high
level so i created a spreadsheet that i
trusted truly with factors for man hours
and how long each product takes to put
in by either square footage or linear
footage or whatever and then i had a guy
who his super power was extreme focus
and he loved it and he still loves it
and for that reason he's good for the
role and i'm horrible for the role and
one thing i often say is that i'm
constantly looking to fire myself from
cert every position i can in the orb so
i'm going higher higher up the board
itself yeah yeah if you want freedom
then you then you definitely have to
remove yourself you know from the
day-to-day tasks you wanna you wanna be
the guy that flies up to altitude at
thirty thousand feet like an airliner
and you just kind of walk down a
landscape and you see okay there's a
big-ass river over there and i see the
mountains over there and flat plains
over here and you see all the farmland
that's basically what you what you
should end up doing as an entrepreneur
you shouldn't be on the ground farming
the land you shouldn't be dealing with
any of the day-to-day stuff you should
have people on those tasks that's what
smart guys do
i absolutely agree with you and
one thing i'd added that is
for me getting up there
and looking at the machine and the cogs
themselves which would be the you know
the systems and processes
is where i really enjoy because it's
quite a creative
thing to do to really think about the
psychology of the sales script
or
um the way people are going to take uh
for us like a pre-qualification package
of where we're like talking about our
safety or quality our production and how
we get things done uh certifications
things like that things that i believe
where i get to sit in the client's shoes
and think about okay what really matters
to this individual when we go out on a
project for them
i enjoy being at 30 000 feet like you're
saying because it really allows you and
this is a
gerber thing it's like you know the
entrepreneur the manager and the
entrepreneur excuse me the technician
manager and entrepreneur i like being up
top and engineering the systems and the
cogs that run together that make the
business run as an actual business from
outside of it
and it seems like anybody that's
successful to any degree
generally they're able to find a way to
step outside the business
and not be a technician any longer did
you start that by the way
uh that's e-myth i did e-myth for two
years okay yeah yeah yeah so so there's
lots of resources out there like that um
you know e-myth is a really good one
there's uh there's a stuff i think it's
gazelles um what the hell's his name
i met him at a conference once he's very
popular vern harnish i think it was
you know he's got another really good
system too but um all you got to do
really i mean if you don't have the
money to buy those courses and you know
the systems and learn how to do all that
stuff
read biographies like uh everything
store which is basically on amazon and
jeff bezos or
losing my
[Music]
virginity which is on richard branson
and you start to see like patterns that
like exist and all these different
high-level billionaires that today don't
work in their business they're basically
like
doing doing the 30 000 footed altitude
sort of job and having leaders and
directors take care of the day-to-day
important stuff
and they only get involved when they're
needed to to deal with very significant
decisions right
no i absolutely agree with you i talk to
about three or four people every day
that manage
either a business or a major division in
a business and then i get the reports
and then weekly we do a meeting
where we go over statistics by position
in the ord board and it's very helpful
to me to make my decisions or who i'm
going to pick up the phone and call to
try to help because like management has
always gotten people back they kind of
get off you got them back
but most of my week is free because
we're measuring by statistics
people understand the five roles and
responsibilities of their position in
the workboard and then based off of
numbers not emotion now whether i like
the person or not we make decisions on
hiring firing
and our coaching and getting somebody
back on the right track just kind of
guiding them back to where they need to
be or fixing some small rock or
something in the cog to make it then
again run smooth um so
yeah man i'm gonna have to check that
book out i might have to get you to text
it to me because
that's that's another thing about
entrepreneurship i'd be interested to
know that from you
you